hidden high up in the Rocky Mountains of
Colorado at a remote and on marked field
is a secret monument honoring War
veterans the lonely tower of granite
sits at more than 11,000 feet in a
clearing among majestic Peaks CBS Sunday
morning and CBS national correspondent
Lee Cowan made the long trek to the
soldier stone to unlock the mysteries
surrounding it Lee joins us now Lee good
morning morning Tony there is a lot of
talk this time of year about the spirit
of giving but this is a story about duty
duty the drove one man to build a very
special gift
that to this day remains a bit of a
mystery the Continental Divide that
invisible mountain boundary that tells a
river whether to flow east or west but
not everything up here is that clear-cut
in a stand of trees impossibly alone
sits this pillar of polished granite
just what it is and how it got all the
way up here has puzzled the hardy few
who have found it for decades they just
stumble on to go what the heck is this
but we still don't really know that
right that makes people think Rob Roy
isn't comfortable talking about this
mountaintop mystery in part because he
made a vow of silence to the man who
built it his late uncle Lieutenant
Colonel Stuart Allen Beckley the soldier
behind soldier stone this is kind of
contrary to what uncle Allen may have
wanted now he doesn't want the the beat
the drum but I I'm beating a drum for
him and a lot of other people are by all
accounts Colonel Beckley was a soldier
soldier he served for nearly a decade in
Southeast Asia during the Vietnam War
you know anything about Special Forces
Green Berets they're the people that
parachute behind the lines and they work
with indigenous people and help them
defend themselves but most of what he
was doing then he couldn't really talk
about correct
the troops he trained and served with
had been secretly recruited by the CIA
made up mostly of mung and Lauda sent
this secret army took tens of thousands
of casualties fighting communism in
Southeast Asia lives that otherwise
might have been American but for decades
the US government denied their sacrifice
in a recording Colonel Beckley made
after he retired it was clear that
ignoring those foreign fighters haunted
him long after the war had ended I made
a silent promise to myself that they
would have their memorial and it would
not just be in Asia but their memorial
would be in the United States as camp
Atreus of ours I mean this was a mission
in 1990 colonel Beckley set out to build
his tribute with the help of a stone
cutter by the name of Mike Donaldson so
when he first described what he wanted
to do what did you think I thought he
was a quack at first and within 30
minutes I know he wasn't did he explain
why he was building it it kind of got
revealed to me over time he did want it
remote and the people that needed to
find it would find it just on top of the
world
this long-forgotten videotape documented
the construction civilians active duty
and retired veterans made up the small
army who unloaded 8 tons of hand-carved
granite
not just for the pillar but 36 so-called
quote stone weighing 300 pounds apiece
edged with a poem or a proverb written
in Laotian Thai Vietnamese among other
languages that were then scattered like
fallen troops around the monument itself
in the summer of 1995 colonel Beckley's
memorial to foreign fighters was finally
finished it was the same year Colonel
Beckley died of cancer he never saw his
offering in person
when we walked away it was it was done
that was the end of it besides a few
people that stumbled across it on the
Continental Divide Trail nobody knew it
was there until this happened we come
across this memorial out in the middle
of nowhere
in 2013 a youtube post appear the secret
of soldier stone was out I read that the
park rangers keep this location private
we have tried very hard as much as we
can to respect his his vision that it
would be a spot where people would just
sort of find it ranger Tristram post
will help you find Colonel Beckley's
soldier stone but only if you ask
she doesn't publicize the exact location
and neither will we
so this is the official folder that we
keep in here I've never seen this that's
very good
rob roy's had only seen pictures his
uncle's dreams McDonald s'en hadn't seen
it since he built it so it's not a walk
in the park
so they made the long drive in fresh
fallen snow and then began the long high
you have to really want to pay your
respects way up here Mikey
you know how much I appreciate you come
join me up here okay I mean it's cool
once there the solitude is part of the
experience as is leaving a token of
military service for eternity right
after a quiet pause it was time to go
and they like everyone left soldier
stone to its isolation I think the
colonel would be proud oh I'm sure he's
proud right now especially the memories
of those now no longer forgotten now
though the Forest Service does watch
over the memorial it's been essentially
volunteers who really keep it up they
managed the collection of mementos they
make sure that there's no graffiti to
clean up trash and things like that so
in the end of the day really Colonel
Beckley did essentially what he wanted
him to do yeah but I guess the irony is
that an act that selfless
I guess it's but he saw the video you
said of them building it you saw the
video of them building it so he had a
sense that he was very particular
they're reams and reams of letters that
he wrote to the stonecutter into the
foresters and everything else about
exactly how he wanted we know how he
decided where to put it
he did want to promote as you heard he
had some private land in in Colorado
that he was thinking about putting it on
but he didn't think that was quite right
and for some reason he this spot spoke
to him and when he wouldn't ask the
Forest Service could I put it there they
started all the procedure did you know
about Italy it's such a beautiful
tribute to them people who've really
died for this country huh you know you
know it was funny was a producer of ours
who was searching on the internet for
other things for stories and he happened
to hit on this Google image of this and
he wondered what it was and we started
looking into it and we found that that
that social media post and it went from
there but it was it was hard to get
folks to talk about it because they
really didn't want to dishonor his
memory he wanted no association with it
he just wanted it there and the guy say
I love the idea that the people who need
to find him
that's exactly what I was - no yeah yeah
yeah beautiful piece Thanks